did you guys have that one really cool
teacher in school like
yeah like for me it was the it teacher
like he didn't give a [ __ ] about what we
did
but every other teacher in my school at
least was a [ __ ] [ __ ] but there
was just
the one id teacher for me that was
really cool yeah i had that uh that was
our physics teacher in high school he
was such a [ __ ] character and
i don't know if he did it on purpose
just to be entertaining because maybe he
thought that not a lot of kids would
take physics as a major
yeah but i took physics because i just
found physics interesting but
it was just imagine this like middle
aged just completely bold dude
and him trying to teach you about like
how electrons move
and he's carrying around this giant
stick
like i'm talking like like twice the
size of a cricket bath
right like just as thick as a creamy bat
and
and and in like marker it's called the
gentle persuader
oh my god and he would just swing this
thing around
and whenever there was a kid who was
asleep at his desk he would just
get the gentle persuader and just whack
it on the table to
get the kid to wake up it's always the
physics teachers that are like the
[ __ ] nuttiest
right yeah they're always either the
most passionate about it
the absolute clap of a sound that this
thing would make like you could hear it
probably from across the school
of just this giant piece of wood
clapping against another giant piece of
wood and the kids
after a while like after like two weeks
no kid would fall asleep in his class
just because he's just swinging that's
asserting dominance yeah as a teacher
the dominatrix domination dominatrix
right there
no but he was like really cool like he
he made physics really fun for me and i
feel that if
i didn't have him as a teacher i
probably would have found like the whole
all the sciences and physics just really
[ __ ] tedious and boring yeah yeah
yeah it's i remember the first time i
read uh great teacher onizuka
[ __ ] one of my favorite manga of all
time and i remember you should
yeah to to give you a synopsis it's
about like this teacher
who is like a 22 year old delinquent uh
like never finished college i don't
think or like was a drop out to college
and basically he takes over this
delinquent classroom and
just kind of reforms them he doesn't
teach them like
the curriculum he teaches them life
lessons yeah and
it's you know it's a pretty simple
premise but what sells it is how
good of a teacher only zuka is and just
like i wish i had a teacher like that in
my own life yeah that was just you know
you know mr sullivan i.t teacher i'm
never gonna forget you but you know you
you know
only zuka you ain't great teacher
the coolest thing he did was let us call
us let us call him by his first names a
few times
oh yeah that's how you know that's how
you know you know that's how you go damn
right yeah there's
there's a special moment when you're in
your senior year of high school where
your teacher's like
just just call me by my name he's like
my biology tutor was like really nice
she was so cool i i did so many dumb
stuff that she was like she had my back
she was like no no no i got this
those are the other teachers because i
oh go uh because like one time when i
got in a fight a different time from the
other stories
yeah out of the million fights yeah she
was pregnant
and like um she was teaching a class
and this guy so one of the guys was i
was having a fight with him and i
[ __ ] rammed him
through her like a class door and the
door slammed open
like absolutely like smacked her like
whiteboard and stuff and i made so much
noise
and uh yeah she didn't tell me off she
was like it's okay
she was like she was like i know he's a
piece of [ __ ]
yeah i got you dude this kid drove all
the teachers insane he was the worst bro
he always got away with it because the
teachers just stopped like do you ever
have that kid where the teacher
just gave up yeah because they're like
he's such a piece of [ __ ] there's no
point even trying to discipline yeah
yeah yeah he's that kid
i'm sure you guys name it yeah we we all
i think we all have that one kid yeah